truc là qui sortent des oreilles là
c'est ça c'est le souffle divin
non mais faut essayer de semaine dans le
monde parce que sinon vous n'avez pas
comprendre
[Musique]
l'or est pour nous le matériau le plus
précieux inoxydable et doré comme le
soleil il a servi dans de nombreuses
sociétés pour fabriquer les objets de
grand prestige vous l'avez déjà vu sur
cette chaîne en grèce à l'époque
mycénienne ce sont des feuilles d'or qui
prennent les traits des rois au mexique
de l'époque classique toutefois le
matériau le plus précieux n'est pas un
métal doré mais une pierre verte le jade
souvent d'un vert profond comme la
jungle qui avait englouti les sites
mayas les masques et bijoux de jade sont
devenus les emblèmes de cette
civilisation mystérieuse représentation
iconique à la fois réaliste et hautement
symbolique elles lisent beaucoup de la
pensée des anciens mayas aujourd'hui je
vous propose donc d'analyser cette
pierre arz du commun le jade chez les
mayas
en guise de préliminaire n'a il faut
d'abord se pencher sur la matière
première les géologues distingue en
réalité plusieurs types de jade l'aja
des hits et lan néphrite ces deux termes
dérive pourtant de la même origine d'une
observation qu'on fait au 16e siècle
les espagnols en débarquant au nouveau
monde les concurrents mentionne en effet
que les indigènes utilise de la pierre
verte comme annuler est en particulier
pour se prémunir des calculs rénaux le
rein ce dîner frau en grec et les
pierres vertes se voir rapidement
qualifié de néphrite les pierres du rhin
le mot jade vient lui du terme irada en
espagnol ce qui signifie le flanc flanc
avec un c'est un non pas sa science a là
encore parce que les indigènes portée
des pierres vertes sur le côté du corps
avec ces deux noms néphrite et jadéite
les géologues distingue deux types de
pierres vertes la première lan et frites
et de la famille des amphiboles c'est un
silicate de calcium et de magnésium
c'est ce jade qui est utilisée dès
l'antiquité en chine mais il est en fait
absents d'amérique les mayas utilisé e
le deuxième type là jadéite c'est une
roche de la famille des pyroxène composé
de sodium et d'aluminium et je voulais
même la formule pour les connaisseurs
vous voyez je peux faire des vidéos de
géologie non quand même faut pas
déconner d'ailleurs une belle chaîne de
géologie que je vous conseille si vous
ne la connaissez pas encore celle de
valentine sciences de comptoir c'est
excellent c'est très drôle je crois que
l'âge des cailloux un moment non mais ça
vaut le coup c'est beaucoup elle est
bien connue des préhistoriens européen
parce que néolithique les jadéite était
aussi prisé pour fabriquer des haches
celles provenant des gisements alpin ont
même été échangés à l'échelle de tout le
continent on en retrouve en bretagne en
écosse au danemark bref le jade c'est
une roche dure à se situe aux alentours
de 6,7 sur l'échelle de moss c'est une
roche métamorphique c'est à dire qu'elle
se forme en profondeur au niveau de la
rencontre de plaques tectoniques à de
hautes pressions et des températures de
300 à 400 degrés les gisements de jade
utilisé par les mayas sont donc situé le
long de la faille de motagua au
guatemala à la jonction entre la plaque
tectonique nord américaine et caraïbe
ces gisements sont exploités pendant
plusieurs millénaires et sont au coeur
d'un grand commerce à l'échelle de
l'amérique centrale
en réalité le jade peut prendre un grand
nombre de teintes du blanc au noir en
passant par le rose ou le bleu mais
celles qui ont exercé le plus d'attrait
sont ces nuances de vert ce sont les
inclusions de différents minéraux
additionnel qui font varier sa couleur
mais évidemment sans la possibilité de
réaliser des années chimiques les mayas
ne distinguer les différentes pierres
que par leur aspect leur origine et leur
qualité artisanale d'autres pierres
vertes ont d'ailleurs été utilisée au
mexique anciens comme l'amazone it la
serpentine à la quitte et la turquoise
certaines obsidienne du verre volcanique
peuvent aussi présenter des reflets
verts c'est le cas de celle de
teotihuacan commercer avec les mayas -
durée prestigieuses ces pierres partager
tout de même grâce à leurs nuances de
vert certaines qualités du jade vous
l'avez compris le point le plus
important pour eux c'est que ce soit
vers
un accord
le plus important pour eux c'est que ce
soit vers c'est cette couleur qui
véhiculent une symbolique importante et
on y reviendra juste après
le jade et travaillé depuis une époque
ancienne la civilisation maire de la
mésoamérique les olmèques installé au
bord du golfe du mexique au deuxième
millénaire avant jésus-christ sont les
premiers à produire des objets en jade
ils produisent notamment des haches
toutefois plus sophistiqués et décoré
que celle du néolithique européen le
travail du jade roche dure est précieuse
et confia des artisans spécialisés et on
a la chance d'avoir fouillé et documenté
précisément plusieurs ateliers du monde
maya le plus important est celui de caen
kuen située à 120 km au nord des
gisements qui a fonctionné entre le 7e
et le xème siècle de notre ère à cancun
ce ne sont pas seulement des éclats de
jade et des déchets de taille qui ont
été découverts mais aussi grande partie
des outils employés par les artisans
percutant en pierre durepos l'histoire
mais aussi plus étonnant des forêts
rotatif aider s'ils accordent pour
découper les blocs non mais c'est
incroyable le siège à la corde est une
technique très ancienne d'ailleurs aussi
à tester au néolithique en europe grâce
aux simples mouvements d'une corde en
matières végétales monté sur un archet
les artisans s'attaquer aux pierres les
plus durs alors comment ça se passe les
cordelettes entraîne avec elle de la
matière abrasive qu'on a ajouté donc
généralement c'est du sable de quartz
d'obsidienne ou même de jade
le tout arrosé d'eau et avec de
l'adresse de la force et surtout
beaucoup de patience les artisans
pouvait les poupées précisément les
blocs de jade pour obtenir des
plaquettes de la forme souhaitée
l'abrasif pouvait aussi éventuellement
être utilisé avec des couteaux de silex
ou d'obsidienne directement sur la
pierre dans tous les cas je vous raconte
pas et en egypte un tabac dans la
technique là mais vous plaignez d'autant
que c'est jamais assez longue balle à la
joue là je m'exécute ah bah oui nommé de
façon quand on parle d'art qui eux aussi
voulaient du plus long c'est forcément
plus technique on part dans la géo l'on
part dans les dents les techniques de
taille et compagnie voilà le polissage
se faisait sur des pierres tendres puis
avec des roseaux qui sont des végétaux
riches en silice et enfin l'objet est
illustré avec une peau comme souvent
simplement avec du bois des cordes de
l'ingéniosité et du temps les artisans
des temps anciens faisait des merveilles
travail de jade était donc un artisanat
bien rodée et très spécialisé chez les
mayas cette pierre verte extraordinaire
était utilisé pour fabriquer divers
objets de prestige pendentif ornements
d'oreilles etc mais les plus fascinants
sont bien entendu les masques mortuaires
[Musique]
une quinzaine de masques ont été
découverts à ce jour dans le monde maya
dans plusieurs grands sites tels que
palenque callac mots ou tikal pour les
plus connus il était déposé dans les
sépultures des souverains des cités
états soit directement sur le visage
soit à côté fabriqué à l'aide de
tesselles de jade coller à la résine sur
une âme de bois ils ont été retrouvés à
l'état de fragments parce que les
matières organiques se sont désagrégées
les archéologues ont donc remonter
patiemment les tesselles de jade pour
reconstituer les visages au plus près de
l'original malheureusement il existe peu
de photos des masques au moment de
retrouvailles et les principales
publications mexicaine qui documentent
justement le travail de reconstitution
sont indisponibles en france ou sur
internet on a quand même réussi à
trouver quelques exemples pour
lesquelles ces informations sont
accessibles par l'hôte ce qui va être
compliqué pour cette vidéo
c'est qu'il existe très peu de photos
très peu d illustrations sont d'une
qualité déplorable vous allez voir
souvent la même illustration pour tel
tondent telle masse que ta ta ta c'est
comme ça je suis dégoûté parce que je
suis allé visiter tous ces sites en 2015
on a volé mon appareil photo
dont la volée secondo cela ça aurait été
bien utile quelques quelques images le
plus emblématique et qui trône en
majesté dans un avion spécial du musée
d'anthropologie nationale à mexico entre
nous plus beau musée du monde et le
masque de pacal le souverain de la cité
de pal à quai entre nous le plus beau
site archéologique monde au septième
siècle de notre ère la dernière
restauration de ce masque a été réalisée
entre 2001 et 2003 pour tenter
d'approcher davantage les traits de son
illustre modèle les archéologues ont pu
céder de deux sculptures en stuc et en
argile qui représentait le souverain ou
déposés dans sa tombe sur ce masque les
artisans ont utilisé six teintes
différentes de jade employés dans des
parties distinctes du visage pour
souligner les éléments importants les
teintes plus vives dit jade impérial
sont employées au centre du visage pour
attirer le regard cette variété rare de
jade était la plus prisée aux temps
anciens comme aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le
vin profond provient de sa composition
chimique original ici ce sont des
minéraux de chrome qui rend place
l'aluminium le remontage du masque a
permis de mettre en évidence que le roi
de palenque avait subies dans son
enfance une déformation céphalique alors
c'est une pratique très répandue dans
leur histoire assise maya qu'il a
pratiqué sur le crâne encore malléables
des nourrissons à l'aide de planches est
attaché à l'arrière de la tête là comme
ça et donc cette déformation artificiel
était fait pour donner une forme
oblongue à la tête c'est à dire en forme
d'épis de maïs et donc les cheveux comme
ça la redresser sur la tête ressembler
au soin de l'épi alors c'est étrange on
verra que c'est un symbole récurrents
sauf que cette coutume à pas vous faire
pour ressembler à abraham simpson a en
plus pour conséquence un développement
asymétrique du visage concrètement ça
veut dire que vous avez une joue pour ce
que l'autre est un méchant strabisme si
vous êtes un roi maya vous pouvez pas
vous permettre d'être symétrique là où
ça devient intéressant c'est que cette
asymétrie se retrouve aussi sur les
masques de jade c'est le cas pour celui
de takhal qui a le côté droit plus
protubérants que le gauche mais
l'exemple le plus frappant est celui du
masque de revenir au sein ou le
strabisme divergent du personnage
apparaît clairement pour le masque de
calakmul dont les 97 et celle de jade
ont été remontés avec précision cela
montre encore une fois une déformation
frontale oblique avec des conséquences
sur les arcades et les pommettes la
symétrie est visible le côté droit est
plus proéminente le gauche à auch
clintock l'une des plus anciennes cités
du nord du yucatan un masque de jade a
aussi été retrouvée dans une tombe
princière il est composé de tesselles
très fine presque translucides par
endroits là encore la symétrie est
visible le côté droit et proéminents et
le côté gauche est plein la déformation
du crâne visible sur les masques associe
donc clairement le souverain odieux maïs
et fait de lui un nourricier pour son
peuple mais au delà de ça ce sont tous
les éléments en jade qui participe de
cette symbolique
[Musique]
pierre verte dont les teintes les plus
prisés sont celles des feuilles de maïs
le jade est associé dès les périodes
anciennes à cette plante indispensables
au mexique on l'a vu le jade est déjà
utilisé par les olmèques au premier
millénaire avant notre ère pour produire
des hd corées se sont en réalité déjà
des images du 'jamais' et elle témoigne
de l'association ancienne entre la
pierre verte et la fertilité les mayas
de l'époque classique entre 250 et 900
après jésus-christ ont donc hérité de
cette signification on voit encore une
fois dans la tombe de pacal en plus de
son masque mortuaire le souverain était
doté de colliers et bracelets en perles
de jade deux bagues de grandes perles
déposé dans ses mains et sur ses pieds
est aussi une statuette du dieu maïs
crocodile retrouver au niveau du bassin
ah non mais bienvenue chez les mayas
c'est pas fini je continue mais au moins
vous savez où vous mettez les pieds en
fait qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le
symbolisme est présent dans tous les
éléments les bracelets de pacal par
exemple sont composées de huit rangs de
25 perdre 8 étant le chiffre associés
aux dieux maïs la forme ronde des perles
et leur polissage minitieux rappelle
aussi les grains de maïs à maturité
lapierre verte est par ailleurs réputés
exhaler le souffle divin elle est censée
produire de la vapeur l'humidité qui
rend fertile elle est en quelque sorte
une manifestation physique du souffle
vital en somme le souverain comme le
grain de maïs semés et ensevelis et
attend sa résurrection grâce aux eaux du
monde souterrain
non mais c'est que l imagination quand
même les boucles d'oreilles proéminente
évoque elle aussi le vent et les pluies
bref la fertilité c'est ça ce qui sort
des boucles d'oreilles
c'est le souffle livre oui
comme ça c'est pas fini c'est pas fini
en 1/4 encore plus ouf dans une tombe
plus ancienne du même site un masque de
jade prend cette fois ci les traits d'un
jaguar et même surmonté d'une coiffe
d'oiseaux le visage est encerclé par une
rangée de tesselles de coquillages le
dignitaire défunt est ici complètement
assimilées à des figures mythologiques
le jaguar et les coquillages renvoyant
tous les deux monde souterrain celui
qu'il faut traverser pour renaître ici
aussi le souverain attend sa
résurrection en tant que dieu maïs coûte
et y en a qui veulent des rolex ben y en
a d'autres et voulait être un épi de
maïs je ne sais pas entre avait sur sa
vie avec une rolex ou en ce moment un
épi de maïs qu'est-ce qui
le jade joue donc un rôle religieux
primordial symbole de vie et fertilité
il est décrit dans la mythologie maya
comme l'un des éléments originels du
monde mais s'il a été exploitée pour ses
qualités mystique il a aussi lu des
usages plus profane
traditionnellement la circulation du
jade chez les mayas se faisait entre
personnages de la noblesse elle
constituée souvent la donne des femmes à
marier on trouve ainsi des bijoux de
jada copan ou duras inscrit d'une onde
d'aristocrates de palenque à plus de 400
km au nord-ouest ce qui témoigne sans
doute d'un mariage à longue distance ces
bijoux éléments de parure prestigieux ne
pouvait être possédé que par une élite
ces échanges sont donc plus des cadeaux
que des transactions monétaires ils
prennent place dans une relation
interpersonnelle entre gens de la haute
et ne peuvent pas régler des dépenses du
quotidien avec des inconnus mais
aujourd'hui certains pensent que le jade
a pu jouer dans certains cas le rôle de
monnaie dans leur article de 2018
intitulé fifty shades of green brigitte
kovacevic et michael callaghan estime
que les perles de jade auraient pu être
utilisés pour régler des transactions
commerciales petite facile à transporter
elles ont pu servir de monnaie d'échangé
enfilés en collier elles deviennent
l'équivalent d'une bourse pour les
pièces de monnaie en afrique et dans
l'océan indien l'utilisation de pertes
de coquillages en guise de né est par
ailleurs à tester largement alors
pourquoi pas le jade la plus grande
production de perles de jade à la fin de
la période classique notamment par
l'atelier de cancun dont on a déjà parlé
semble indiquer un glissement vers
l'utilisation monétaire les perles de
meilleure qualité restes trouvés dans
les tombes de l'aristocratie mais les
perles plus banal sont répartis de
manière assez homogène dans les sites
tardif les h ange a dit aurait aussi pu
jouer le même rôle de forme assez
régulières elles s'apparentent à des
lingots et aurait pu régler des
transactions plus conséquente en
complément des ternes une théorie
innovatrice qu'il faudra soumettre aux
futures découvertes en résumé qu'il soit
symbole de renouveau et de fertilité
support des expressions artistiques les
plus aboutis ou simple monnaie des
changes les objets jazz reste un
témoignage particulièrement précieux
pour la connaissance du monde maya au
coeur de la mythologie et des croyances
dans l'au delà cette pierre a fasciné
les anciens mayas et continuent de
passionner les visiteurs des musées
archéologiques
finalement n'est pas si différent des
mailles un bon après faut avoir envie de
se réincarner en épis de maïs ça c'est
encore autre chose
je vous remercie d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a plu
surtout n'hésitez pas à la partager
c'est très important pour le
la réincarnation de la chaîne non non
mais sans rire c'est très important pour
pour les créateurs d'être soutenue de
bas de toutes les manières possibles
fait en fonction de votre situation et
un évidemment un like un partage un
commentaire ou un don via les
plateformes type youyous type et ça
permet de de pouvoir produire
tranquillement sereinement du contenu
sur youtube je vous remercie je vous
souhaite et bien une très bonne semaine
et je vous dis à la prochaine salut
[Musique]
marre marre marre marre marre